und jetzt das heute journal
mit heinz wolf und marietta slomka guten
abend mehr als 16.700 neue infektionen
meldet heute dass rk ii wenn das so
weitergeht sind wir sehr bald bei den
19.000 die angela merkel ursprünglich
mal als schreckensvisionen für
weihnachten avisierte zwei wochen ist es
her dass sich kanzlerin und
ministerpräsidenten bei ihrer krone
gipfel mit mühe und not auf ein paar
gemeinsame regeln einigten
gebracht hat das offenkundig nicht viel
merkel ja damals schon das reicht nicht
in zwei wochen sehen wir uns wieder so
ist es gekommen
mit den beschlüssen die gestern gefasst
wurden sind wir nun wieder da wo wir
früher schon mal waren beim kollektiven
platten zu kurz was die bundeskanzlerin
dazu heute im parlament sagte und wie
die oppositionsparteien reagieren hat
thomas reichert beobachtet mitten in
dieser hitzigen debatte wird plötzlich
die maske von alexander dobrindt wichtig
weil sie die tiefe corona kluft im
bundestag ziemlich gut auf den punkt
bringt mit maske begeht der zu reden er
hat sich irgendwie daran gewöhnt derweil
regt sich die afg über masken und
insgesamt über die neuen corona
einschnitte so laut wird es dass merkel
zu beginn ihrer rede kaum durchdringt
die maßnahmen die wir jetzt ergreifen
müssen sind geeignet erforderlich und
verhältnismäßig es gibt insbesondere
meine klappe herzen
warum nicht wenn sie den präsidenten
unterbrechen kriegen sie gleiche
ordnungsrufe dass ich gefährlich
eigentlich will merkel den neuen krone
lockdown erklären sie warnt davor dass
sich das land in einer dramatischen lage
befinde und noch vor etwas anderen lüge
und der information verschwörung und
hass beschädigen nicht nur die
demokratische debatte sondern auch den
kampf gegen das wirklich gemeint ist die
hfg die korona verharmlost und gar von
einer corona diktatur auf widerruf
spricht wozu ja auch passt dass wir
neuerdings von einer art kriegs kabinett
dem corona kabinett regiert werden
es hat die größten
freiheitsbeschränkungen in der
geschichte dieser republik beschlossen
aber dass merkel erst jetzt die schweren
eingriffe vor den volksvertretern
erklärt das kritisiere noch andere
es geht um die rechte des parlaments
dass sich von der regierung kalt
gestellt sieht frau merkel wir haben
gesagt debatte stärke die demokratie das
ist richtig dafür muss die debatte aber
vor der entscheidung stattfinden und der
autor entscheidung muss das parlament
sah man kann mit der bevölkerung nicht
so umgehen dass man nur in diesen fragen
regiert in der ministerpräsidenten runde
oder abwechselnd dann mal wieder ein
podcast das geht wirklich nicht sogar
dem koalitionspartner scheint wohl mich
zu werden angesichts all der korona
verordnungen der machtfülle der
regierung selbst in unsicheren zeiten
ist der reflex zum durchregieren keine
alternative zum mühsamen konsens prozess
für die union aber steht noch etwas
anderes auf dem spiel
corona ist zum stresstest gewordene der
auseinandersetzung mit diktaturen wie
china
totalitäre autoritäre systeme kommen mit
mitteln die wir nicht einsetzen wollen
besser mit dieser pandemie zu recht als
wir und es geht darum dass wir als
offene demokratische plurale
gesellschaft beweisen dass wir diese
pandemie auch in den griff bekomme alter
am montag geht das mit diesen eingriffen
merkel spricht am ende von einem langen
schweren winter aber auch der verdi
händen es klingt zumindest ein bisschen
vielen versprechen von normalität im
verlauf ihrer regierungserklärung heute
im bundestag bezog sich merkel auch auf
ein heute journal interview mit der
wissenschaftsjournalistin martin kind um
das virus für laien besser verständlich
zu machen hatte sie ist gewissermaßen
personalisierte warum das virus menschen
mag und sie für hervorragende
verbreitungs wird erhält bei menschen
weltweit so mobil sind und sich gerne in
wechselnden populationen und herden
aufhalten oder bildung ist menschlich
etwa bei festen für die man sogar von
weit her anreist viel mobilität und
viele unterschiedliche menschen in einem
raum das soll nun wieder weitgehend
vermieden werden
und wieder sind es gastronomen
veranstalter künstler aber auch
hoteliers und die reisebranche die es am
härtesten trifft den der staat aber auch
helfen will
dominik möller rosell berichtet große
kleine und der mittelstand konzerne
einzelunternehmen solo selbständige der
vizekanzler und der
bundeswirtschaftsminister wollen an alle
denken und dafür sorgen dass die hilfen
tatsächlich auch bei allen ankommen die
sie benötigen
bis zu zehn milliarden euro finanzhilfen
insgesamt das gab es noch nie in dieser
größenordnung bisher unbekannte
unterstützungsleistung für die von den
schließungen entscheidungen erfassten
branchen es gelingt uns durch die
fokussierung nicht nur das geschehen im
hinblick auf die infektion in griff zu
bekommen so ist die zielsetzung die wir
verfolgen mit diesem massiven maßnahmen
sondern eben auch konkret diesen
unternehmen zu helfen
eines davon die althoff hotel gruppe in
köln
1800 mitarbeiter 15 häuser die
allermeisten machen sie nun dicht wären
sie ein kleines unternehmen erhielten
sie 75 prozent des umsatzes von november
2009 10
wären sie ein mittelgroßes erhielten sie
immerhin noch 70 prozent
aber sie sind ein zu großes und weil die
eu beihilfe richtlinien ins spiel kommen
erhalten sie vermutlich deutlich weniger
als 70 prozent eine zu große
ungleichbehandlung also zunächst
begrüßen wir dass die bundesregierung
über beihilfe programme die betroffenen
unternehmen versucht zu unterstützen
wichtig ist dass hier jedes unternehmen
in relation zu seinem umsatz nämlich 70
75 bei den kleineren und 70 prozent bei
den größeren zu denen wir gehören auch
er hält und es nicht eine deckelung gibt
wo am ende eine weit unterproportionale
beihilfe für unternehmen wie das unsrige
zur verfügung gestellt wird
mainz grobe leitlinie klar doch viele
details noch ungeklärt eine berufsgruppe
werde man nun allerdings fest im blick
haben verspricht der wirtschaftsminister
ist ein großer erfolg dass es gelungen
ist auch die solo selbständige die die
voraussetzungen werden schlüssel
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz in diese
leistungen mit einzubeziehen
vor allem menschen aus der
veranstaltungsbranche betrifft hass wie
christoph kolbow für die die bisherigen
maßnahmen wie etwa überbrückungshilfen
nicht griffen weil die hürden um an
diese hilfen ranzukommen einfach zu hoch
gewesen sein
hoffentlich wird das zumindest nun
anders hofft er
sollte das so banal kommen wie s
ausgesprochen worden ist 75 prozent von
einem vergleichbaren monat aus dem jahr
2019 oder dem november
das würde den leuten jetzt für einen
monat bis anderthalb monate tatsächlich
helfen aber dann sind wir im dezember
und dann der bund habe noch einige
schüsse frei versucht vizekanzler scholz
heute zu beruhigen ab wann betroffene
firmen nun die november hilfen
beantragen können ist noch unklar
zeitnah heißt es dazu
es ist nicht nur die zahl der
neuinfektionen die bundes und
landesregierungen auf schreckt auch
andere faktoren entwickeln sich in die
falsche richtung
es steigt wieder die zahl der älteren
die sich anstecken und es steigt die
zahl der krankenhauspatienten die zahl
der intensiv medizinisch behandelten
cupid 19 fälle hat sich in den
vergangenen zwei wochen sogar mehr als
verdoppelt der verband der intensiv und
notfallmediziner begrüßt daher
ausdrücklich die jetzt neu beschlossenen
maßnahmen man stehe an einem kritischen
punkt von den jetzt infizierten würden
die schweren verläufe erst in zwei drei
oder vier wochen in den kliniken landen
und die großen zentren dann schnell an
die maximalbelastungen in der uniklinik
aachen etwa erinnert man sich noch gut
an die erste welle
jetzt geht es wieder los sagt der
klinikdirektor zu unserem reporter torge
bode
sonntag seit sonntag liegt dieser
patient im koma sein zustand so schlecht
dass er künstlich beatmet werden muss
der mann ist 48 jahre alt er ist einer
von 13 kurven 19 patienten die auf der
intensivstation der uniklinik aachen
liegen die zweite welle ist hier
angekommen und sie beginnt anders als
die erste in der ersten welle doch sehr
viele ältere patienten versorgt es war
noch einige jüngere dabei aber dieses
mal sind es quasi fast nur jüngere heißt
jetzt für uns vernünftig und etwas
jünger und noch etwas ist hier in aachen
anders als im frühjahr
es sind deutlich mehr schwerst erkrankte
patienten aus belgien die sie aufnehmen
allein fünf in den letzten tagen belgien
hat er sich zeit gelassen mit neuen
schärferen regeln wohl zu lange so sieht
es der chefarzt in aachen
[Musik]
es führt wenn wir diese maßnahmen zu
spät treffen
da kommen von eben dann doch irgendwann
an kapazitätsgrenzen und von der
eben jetzt daneben auch vermehrt
wirklich so patienten während der ersten
welle mussten in spitzenzeiten knapp 50
corona patientinnen und patienten hier
an der uni klinik künstlich beatmet
werden
eine hohe belastung für das gesamte
personal
doch jetzt profitiert man auch von den
gesammelten erfahrungen sehr
standardisierte abläufe gehabt die fans
jetzt einfach standard die sie wieder
hoch
das bringt uns großen benefit auch wenn
noch mehr patienten kommen dass man
einfach einen standardbrief man diese
patienten behandelt und diesen standard
abruft wie man die zweite welle hier
bewältigen wird das hängt auch von den
personalkapazitäten ab engpässe gibt es
teilweise schon jetzt in vielen kliniken
durch eigene ansteckung mit 19 oder
quarantänebestimmungen und denen die
jetzt wieder an vorderster front kämpfen
steckt noch immer die belastung der
ersten welle in den knochen
keine zeit zum durchatmen denn die zahl
der schwer und schwerst erkrankten
kurbelt patienten wird deutschlandweit
steigen zwei prozent der mit corona
infizierten müssen intensivmedizinisch
behandelt werden so die erfahrung
sorgen werden müssen als in der ersten
welle in der ersten meldung war knapp
103.000 ich befürchte wir müssen
jedenfalls irgendwie ist man sie hoffen
die herausforderungen hier in aachen zu
meistern
auch dieses mal bis zum ende der zweiten
bälle aber es wird wieder allen vieles
abverlangen
nur das thema spricht im anschluss uns
heute schon mal auch maybrit illner mit
ihren gästen unter dem titel die welle
brechen wie weit fährt deutschland
herunter und natürlich finden sie jede
menge informationen rund um corona auch
auf zdf heute.de und jetzt macht es
erstmal weiter mit den nachrichten ja
auch die staats und regierungschefs der
eu haben über die lage in der korona
pandemie beraten am abend in einer
konferenz per video
es sollte unter anderem um gemeinsame
test und impfstrategien sowie
gegenseitige unterstützung im kampf
gegen das virus gilt eu ratspräsidenten
shell hatte zuvor erklärt es gelte die
gesundheit der bürger zu schützen und
eine nachhaltige wirtschaftliche
erholung auf den weg zu bringen
es gibt neue zahlen vom arbeitsmarkt für
den oktober mit einer positiven
entwicklung nach den daten der
bundesagentur für arbeit waren zwei
millionen 760.000 menschen arbeitslos
das sind 87 1000 weniger als im
september
die quote lag bei 6 prozent im vergleich
zum oktober des letzten jahres gab es
allerdings 556.000 arbeitslose mehr
der bundestag hat eine finanzielle
entlastung für familien beschlossen ab
dem kommenden jahr soll das kindergeld
um 15 euro steigen
die freibeträge für kinder werden
entsprechend erhöht das gesetz geht zur
beratung auch noch an den bundesrat an
der spitze der evangelischen kirche in
deutschland wird es einen wechsel geben
der ratsvorsitzende heinrich bedford
strohm hat heute angekündigt im nächsten
jahr nicht wieder zu kandidieren
es sei gut wenn jemand neues ran komme
und es neue impulse gebe sagte der 60
jährige gegenüber dem bayerischen
rundfunk
bedford strohm ist seit 2014
ratsvorsitzender der ekd bei einem
schiffsunglück vor der küste des
senegals sind nach angaben der
internationalen organisation für
migration mindestens 140 flüchtlinge
ertrunken
die un organisation teilte mit ein
schiff mit etwa 200 menschen an bord sei
am vergangenen wochenende gekentert sie
bezog sich bei der zahl der flüchtlinge
auf dem boot auf die angaben von
augenzeugen die behörden im senegal
hatten zunächst von zehn todesopfern und
60 betten gesprochen
die britische labour partei hat ihren
früheren vorsitzenden corbijn wegen
antisemitismus vorwürfen suspendiert die
entscheidung sei angesichts verharmlosen
der äußerungen corbijns über eine
unabhängige untersuchung zu
judenfeindlichkeit in der
oppositionspartei getroffen worden
teilte eine parteisprecherin mit
in einem bericht der britischen
gleichberechtigungs
un-menschenrechtskommission hieß es die
labour partei unter der führung des
ehemaligen parteichefs habe
antisemitismus in den eigenen reihen
zugelassen
corbijn kündigte an er werde die
suspendierung anfechten
als seien die franzosen mit ihren
heftigen corona zahlen und neuem
lockdown nicht schon geschlagen genug
wird in frankreich jetzt auch noch die
höchste terror warnstufe ausgerufen
mehrere mutmaßlich islamistische
anschläge innerhalb weniger wochen mit
drei toten heute in nizza thomas walde
berichtet aus einen erschütterten land
unmittelbar nach bekanntwerden des
anschlags macht sich emanuel makro auf
den weg nach nizza
der präsident der republik betont die
bedeutung der tat für das ganze land in
front einmal mehr ist unser land von
einem islamistisch terroristischen
angriff getroffen
einmal mehr sind heute morgen drei
unserer landsleute gefallen operiert
dies und den weg es war kurz nach neun
polizisten stürmen in die basilika notre
dame die größte kirche netzers schüsse
fallen drinnen hat ein attentäter
besucher mit einem messer angegriffen
der küster und eine frau sind sofort tot
eine zweite frau flieht nach draußen
stirbt aber kurz darauf die polizei
schießt auf den täter einen 21 jährigen
tunesier
er wird festgenommen der angreifer hat
nicht aufgehört allahu akhbar zu rufen
während er medizinisch versorgt wurde
wir haben gerade erfahren dass es ein
brutales attentat in nizza gegeben hat
sagt der präsident der us national die
nachricht platz denn die debatte zur
krone ausgangssperre die abgeordneten
erheben sich zu einer schweigeminute
das erinnert daran wie die abgeordneten
vor kurzem gemeinsam das ermordeten
lehrer samuel partie gedachten auch bei
diesem anschlag fühlte sich die republik
getroffen partie hatte die mohammed
karikaturen im unterricht behandelt die
republik verteidigte das und ehrte
partie daraufhin brach ein streit
zwischen dem präsidenten und vertretern
muslimischer länder aus französische
muslim verbände stellten sich heute auf
die seite der republik wir sind von der
tat abgestoßen es gibt den versuch
frankreich und die muslime gegeneinander
auszuspielen in diese falle tappen wir
nicht in diese falle tappen wir nicht
doch auch in frankreich gibt es kräfte
die auf konfrontation setzen jeder neue
anschlag ist wasser auf die mühlen der
extremen rechten auch heute
seit jahren führt man gegen uns krieg
wir brauchen ein kriegsrecht dagegen das
sage ich erneut ein spezielles recht für
diesen kampf
terrorismus ist die waffe der
islamistischen ideologie ideologie
präsident makro appellierte dagegen an
die einheit des landes wir erneut
angegriffen werden dann wegen unserer
werte ich sage es heute noch einmal ganz
klar wir erreichen keinen schritt zurück
ins zentrum der präsident hat heute
insgesamt 7000 soldaten abkommandiert
zum schutz von kirchen schulen und den
werten der republik
aber wenn wir noch reden mit peter r
neumann vom londoner king's college
seinen führenden europäischen
extremismusforscher insbesondere experte
für islamistischen terror guten abend
herr neumann
guten abend franken
dann konnte der zeit lang den eindruck
haben dass das nachgelassen hat mit
diesen islamistischen terror attacken
also das hörte nicht ganz auf aber es
wurde gefüllt weniger hat dieser
eindruck getrogen nicht ganz also 2017
mit dem mit der zerstörung des
sogenannten kalifat zensuren und im irak
war erstmal die infrastruktur weg und
zusätzlich dazu gab es natürlich eine
sinnkrise auch unter den europäischen
anhängern des sogenannten islamischen
staates wie konnte es sein dass dieses
vermeintlich tausendjährige reich
plötzlich weg ist aber der virus des
dschihadismus hat natürlich schon
irgendwie sich in bestimmten
gemeinschaften verfestigt und ist noch
da also es gibt natürlich noch anhänger
und es gibt natürlich noch eine gefahr
durch den jihadismus auch jetzt und auch
nach dem ende des sogenannten kalifat
und auch besonders in frankreich
frankreich ist wahrscheinlich in europa
das land das die härteste
auseinandersetzung mit dem islamismus
hat weil es auch das land ist das an
harte ssten den eigenen laizismus die
eigene säkularität praktiziert und
deswegen wird frankreich immer wieder
zum fokus der islamisten und das ist
jetzt der neueste auslöser aber es gab
natürlich auch in der vergangenheit
schon auslöser die kopftuchdebatte die
debatte um die koloniale vergangenheit
die ursache ist letztlich diese
konfrontation und daran hängt sich das
immer wieder auf das sieht man jetzt
auch moment im konflikt mit der türkei
also das gibt es einen regelrechten
streit zwischen erdogan und präsident
erdogan und mark wahlberg makro er würde
eine kampagne gegen den islam führen
dass überhöhte und überwölbt das ganze
ja eigentlich noch absolut und ich denke
die beste art und weise über den
türkischen präsidenten nachzudenken ist
oder sich in vorzustellen ist als einen
populisten versuchte in situationen wo
bereits die spannung sehr groß ist diese
spannung nicht zu deeskalieren sondern
weiter anzuheizen und er macht das weil
ihm das innenpolitisch nützt und weil
ihm das auch in wahrscheinlich in
einigen muslimischen ländern nützt aber
natürlich trägt das dazu bei dass ein
meinungsklima entsteht wo sich
vielleicht möglicherweise einige leute
dazu legitimiert fühlen auch solche
extremen taten durchzuführen macht das
natürlich nicht direkt aber indirekt hat
er schon eine verantwortung dafür dass
diese diese extreme spannung entsteht
und weiter angeheizt wird
frankreich ist ja gerade der laizismus
sehr konsequent ausgelebt also für
gotteslästerung blasphemie ist da auch
verfassungsrechtlich geschützt und das
soll ja auch im unterricht den schülern
mitgeteilt werden
dann berichten aber lehrer in
in frankreich schon lange dass sie sich
bedroht fühlen also dieses problem auch
gerade an schulen ist nicht neu es ist
nicht neu und es hängt sich immer wieder
an neuen themen auf und das ist glaube
ich wirklich das problem dass wir
aktuell eine situation haben in
frankreich ähnlich der in dänemark 2006
wo es ja auch schon mal karikaturen mit
dem propheten mohammed gab und sich eine
ganze internationale kampagne dran
gehängt hat ich glaube deswegen dass
frankreich nach wie vor und auch für
einige zeit noch im fokus der islamisten
stehen wird und wir sehen das auch in
den sozialen medien wenn man sich
anschaut was von dschihadisten aktuell
kommt dann fokussiert sich das sehr auf
frankreich und ich denke diese
auseinandersetzung frankreich gegen die
islamisten das wird das land noch einige
zeit begleiten zumal solche taten dann
ja auch vermutlich immer nachahmertaten
nach sich ziehen also ist das moment
schätzen sie auch die terrorgefahr für
frankreich moment als besonders hoch an
dass dann noch mehr jetzt erstmal in den
nächsten tagen wochen passieren kann
also ich denke es gibt zwei gefahren
jede terroristische anschlag hat immer
auch die absicht nicht nur leute
einzuschüchtern panik und angst zu
verursachen aber eben auch die eigenen
anhänger zu inspirieren und wir sehen
auch dass in den sozialen medien bei
islamistischen kanälen wo gesagt wird
das war einer den müsste jetzt nach
abend deswegen ist in frankreich aber
auch überall in europa die sensibilität
der sicherheitsbehörden momentan
besonders hoch weil man natürlich
befürchten muss dass andere das macht
nachmachen aber die zweite gefahr und
das ist genauso wichtig ist dass eben
von rechtsextremer seite versucht wird
jetzt aus dieser situation kapital zu
schlagen und dass gesagt wird wir müssen
jetzt vergeltung üben und daraus könnten
natürlich teufelskreise oder spiralen
der gewalt entstehen
deswegen ist die situation schon
gefährlich momente es gab ja heute auch
noch einen anschlag in avignon so ganz
geklärt sind die hintergründe dann noch
nicht aber da soll der täter wohl eine 1
eine rechtsradikale rechtsextremistische
jacke oder jacke mit entsprechenden
motiven getragen haben wissen sie dazu
etwas mehr
ja das war also absolut kein islamist
obwohl das am anfang so berichtet wurde
dieser anschlag in avignon oder
versuchte anschlag wurde offensichtlich
von jemanden durchgeführt der der
sogenannten identitäten bewegung nahe
stand der eine jacke der organisation
getragen hat und dessen hintergründe
noch unklar sind es ist auf jeden fall
klar dass es kein islamistischen
anschlag
man danke für diese einschätzungen ja
wiedersehen nach london
danke schön jetzt erst noch mal heinz
wolf zunächst für den blick auf die
finanzmärkte
auch die europäische zentralbank steht
vor der frage wie auf die entwicklungen
der korona krise reagieren
nach einer zinssitzung heute äußerte
sich ezb präsident in lagarde dazu frank
bethmann
wie sieht man die situation bei der ezb
einerseits nüchtern unaufgeregt
andererseits ist die korona situation
natürlich ernüchternd die steigende
infektionszahlen lasten auf europas
wirtschaft die konjunkturellen
aussichten haben sich wieder stark
eingetrübt sofortmaßnahmen verkündete
die ezb chefin heute dennoch nicht die
kommen dafür jetzt im dezember bis dahin
überprüfe man das geldpolitische
instrumentarium spielraum jedenfalls für
den verstärkten ankauf von anleihen ist
da von den 1,35 billionen euro note
programm waren bis ende september
nämlich erst knapp 600 milliarden
ausgeschöpft zu hören wolle sie sagte
lagarde vor einem jahr zu beginn ihrer
präsidentschaft den bürgern die
geldpolitik der europäischen zentralbank
noch besser erklären
in der sache aber blieb sie bislang
stramm auf kurs die geldschleusen stehen
weiterhin wie bei ihrem vorgänger weit
offen
diese aussicht hat die anleger heute
zumindest teilweise wieder in die
aktienmärkte zurück geholt nach einer
achterbahnfahrt schließt der dax am ende
mit 0,3 prozent im plus zuvor vor der
ezb sitzung war der leitindex ins minus
gerutscht erholte sich dann aber wieder
frank wittmann vielen dank
in vietnam sind bei einem taifun und
durch zwei dadurch ausgelöste erdrutsche
mehr als 30 menschen ums leben gekommen
und fast 50 weitere gelten noch als
vermisst
die rettungsarbeiten in der provinz
quang namen gestalten sich schwierig
zufahrtsstraßen werden von tiefem
schlamm bedeckt der taifun mit
windgeschwindigkeiten von bis zu 135
kilometern pro stunde
beschädigte zehntausende häuser gibt es
aus der fußball-europa-league hoffenheim
hat in der gruppenphase am abend bei car
agent mit 4 zu 1 gewonnen
wie gut ist das handynetz quer durch
deutschland darüber gibt ab heute eine
interaktive karte der bundesnetzagentur
auskunft der sogenannte breitband
monitor bis auf die straße genau soll
die verfügbarkeit von allen drei
netzbetreibern dargestellt seien
das interesse an der karte war so groß
dass sie heute kurze zeit nach dem start
nicht mehr erreichbar war
das war es von uns gleich nach dem
wetter geht's wie schon angekündigt bei
maybrit illner weiter und gegen 0.30
gibt es dann unser heute schon mal ein
update mit hanna zimmermann wiedersehen
wiedersehen
[Musik]
liebe zuschauer trübes wetter ist für
morgen angesagt mit viel regen in
norddeutschland aber dieses massive
regengebiet das sorgt dann dafür dass
die kühle luft aus mitteleuropa langsam
nach osten abgedrängt wird und in den
nächsten tagen kann es aus südwesten
deutlich wärmer werden und vielleicht am
montag erwarten wir dann im südwesten
auch bis zu 20 grad ganz anders im
norden von skandinavien
da bleibt es auch tagsüber kühl keine
temperaturen mehr über null grad
zumindest in diesen tagen ja heute nacht
könnte sich bei uns auf etwa 5 bis 11
grad ab dieses massive regengebiet zieht
nach osten weiter
morgen früh liegt der regen der
kräftigste regen zwischen ostsee und
erzgebirge bis hinunter zu den alpen im
westen ist es dann schon wieder trocken
geworden
ja und tagsüber bleibt es dann in
norddeutschland doch ziemlich trüb immer
wieder regnet es teilweise kräftig mit
schauern und zum nachmittag hin könnte
es dann an der nordsee langsam wieder
trockener werden es weht ein kräftiger
westwind dazu in der mitte und im süden
sind die meisten regenschauer tagsüber
durchgezogen liegen anfangs noch über
den östlichen bayern und es lockert auch
auf vor allem am nachmittag aber auch
schon vormittags ii und da sonnige
lücken und zum nachmittag hin werden die
aus dem südwesten etwas größer und es
wird natürlich dann auch wieder etwas
wärmer
meist sind es schon wieder 13 bis 16
grad in den mittelgebirgen um 11 grad ja
das wochenende zumindest der samstag
sieht eigentlich recht freundlich aus
dabei da ist es mal trocken meist auch
sonnig der sonntag allerdings der wird
schon wieder stürmisch an der nordsee
mit schauern in norddeutschland und am
montag ist das ganz ähnlich aber die
temperaturen steigen noch zum teil im
südwesten bis auf 22 grad
ich wünschen noch einen schönen abend
und machen sie es gut